"THE FIVE" ."
WELL, THAT DIDN'T TAKE LONG.
>> NO ONE SETS THE TONE MORE
THAN THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES.
THE TONE HE SETS IS ONE OF
DIVISION, OFTEN ONE OF HATRED.
>> IT'S BECOME A STRUGGLE VERSUS
GOOD VERSUS EVIL AND THE
PRESIDENT THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS EVIL.
>> THIS MAN COME OF THE FLAMES
OF HIS HATRED WERE FANNED BY A
PRESIDENT WHO KEPT TALKING ABOUT
THIS CARAVAN OF REFUGEES AS IF
THEY WERE TERRORISTS.
>> Greg: AS THEY BLAME TRUMPS
WORDS FOR VIOLENCE, DO THEY
REALIZE THEY ARE EXCUSING THE
VIOLENT ACTS THEMSELVES?
WHILE, OFFERING A CASE FOR
LENIENCY FOR THE ACTUAL PURPOSE.
IF THE ACTIONS OF EVILDOERS ARE
OUT OF THEIR OWN CONTROL AND
NOTHING ELSE COULD HAVE LED TO
THE VIOLENCE, THEN HOW CAN YOU
EVEN BEGIN TO PUNISH THESE
CREEPS?
IT'S WRONG.
MEAN WELL FOR BOTH OBAMA AND THE
SHOOTER, PRESIDENT TRUMP,
MR. LAW AND ORDER, PUSHES THE
DEATH PENALTY.
THERE IS NO AMBIGUITY THERE.
HE PLACES THAT BLAME FIRMLY ON
THE DIRT BAGS AND LIKE MOST
REPUBLICANS SEEKS OUT THE
STIFFEST PENALTY LITERALLY THE
STIFFEST.
THIS CONTRADICTS THE MEDIA WHO
SEE TRUMP AS A HATEFUL
RINGLEADER WHO SYMPATHIZES WITH
SUCH CRETINS.
SPEAKING OF THOSE SUSPECTS, THEY
WERE TOTAL LOSERS.
FAILURES IN LIFE WHO PLACED
THEIR RAGE ON OTHERS AND ANYONE
WITH AN OPINION COULD PROVIDE A
TRIGGER.
BECAUSE WORDS CAN INFLUENCE.
IT'S WHY THERE IS ADVERTISING.
BUT THAT'S A SCARY PATH TO TAKE
ESPECIALLY FOR HOLLYWOOD, RAP
STARS, AND VIDEO GAME MAKERS OR
EVEN PEOPLE PAID TO SPEAK
CAREFULLY AND THOUGHTFULLY.
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS RACIST.
>> EVEN ALBERT EINSTEIN --
MAY HAVE ENDED UP IN A NAZI
CONCENTRATION CAMP WITH
DONALD TRUMP VIEWS ON
IMMIGRATION.
>> YOU ARE STANDING AT THE
BORDER, LIKE NAZIS, SAYING YOU
HERE, YOU HERE.
>> Greg: YOU WONT HATE?
SPEND TWO YEARS CALLED THE GUY
HITLER, A RACIST, A TRADER,
INSANE.
THEN YOU BLAME THEM FOR VIOLENCE
BECAUSE OF NICKNAMES.
NO LECTURES FROM YOU.
EVEN MORE, WORDS IS THE CAUSE
ELIMINATES THE SUSPECTS ENTIRE
HISTORY AND A SLEW OF VARIABLES
THAT BROUGHT HIM TO COMMIT HIS
CRIME.
IT MAKES NO SENSE LEGALLY OR
MORALLY BUT POLITICALLY, I GUESS
THAT'S ANOTHER STORY.
AFTER ALL, WHY LET A CRISIS GO
TO WASTE?
EXCEPT THAT HE WILL MAKE ANOTHER
ONE FAR WORSE.
LISA, THEY DIDN'T WASTE ANY
TIME.
I GUESS WE SIDE COMING THAT THEY
WOULD PIN THE BLAME ON TRUMP.
>> Lisa: IF YOU'VE BEEN PAYING
ANY ATTENTION TO THE MEDIA SINCE
PRESIDENT TRUMP ANNOUNCED.
THERE IS A COMPLETE DOUBLE
STANDARD IN THE MEDIA.
WE KNOW THIS.
WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS TO
REPUBLICANS, THE MEDIA ON THE
LEFT SAY THAT WE NEED STABILITY
ON BOTH SIDES.
WHEN SOMETHING HAPPENS AND IT'S
DIRECTED AT DEMOCRATS PERMITS
PURELY PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THE
REPUBLICANS FAULT.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAIL BOMBING
SUSPECT, THIS GUY HAS A RAP
SHEET GOING BACK TO 1991.
HE MADE A BOMBING, TERRORIST
THREAT IN 2002 AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE SYNAGOGUE SHOOTING, THIS
GUY HATED PRESIDENT TRUMP
BECAUSE THEY DIDN'T THINK HE WAS
AN ANTI-SEMITE.
SO IF YOU ACTUALLY LOOK AT THE
FACTS, DOESN'T DRIVE THE
NARRATIVE THAT THE MEDIA'S
DRIVING BUT THE ONLY REASON THEY
DO IT IS BECAUSE THE MIDTERMS
ARE AROUND THE CORNER AND THEY
WANT TO HURT PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> Greg: CAN I PLAY CIRRUS SERA
SANDERS?
>> WHY IS HE OUT THERE?
>> THE VERY FIRST THING THE
PRESIDENT DID WAS CONDEMN THE
ATTACKS IN PITTSBURGH AND THE
PIPE BOMBS.
THE VERY FIRST THING THAT MEDIA
DID WAS BLAME THE PRESIDENT TO
MAKE HIM RESPONSIBLE FOR THESE
RIDICULOUS ACTS.
YOU CAN START PUTTING THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF INDIVIDUALS ON
ANYBODY BUT THE INDIVIDUAL WHO
CARRIES OUT THE CRIME.
HE HAS DELIVERED ON THE PROMISES
HE'S MADE AND IF ANYTHING, I
THINK IT'S SAD AND DIVISIVE THE
WAY THAT EVERY SINGLE THING THAT
COMES OUT OF THE MEDIA, 90% OF
WHAT COMES OUT OF THE MEDIA'S
MOUTH IS NEGATIVE ABOUT THIS
PRESIDENT.
>> Greg: JUAN, MY QUESTION IS
I THINK YOU CAN HOLD TWO
OPINIONS.
THAT TRUMP'S DISCOURSE IS
DIVISIVE.
I CAN SAY THAT.
HE'S PUGNACIOUS.
BUT ALSO THAT MASCULINE IS
RESPONSIBLE FOR THEIR ACTIONS
ALONE.
DON'T YOU THINK TYING THAT
TOGETHER AND PUTTING IT ON HIM
IS POLITICALLY OPPORTUNISTIC?
I LEAD YOU WITH THE ANSWER.
>> Juan: I WANT TO ENGAGE YOU
SERIOUSLY BECAUSE I THINK THIS
IS A SERIOUS TOPIC.
I THINK YOU ARE RIGHT.
THEY ARE TWO THOUGHTS AND THEY
CAN BE HELD SIMULTANEOUSLY.
IN OTHER WORDS, YOU HAVE TO HOLD
THE CULPRIT RESPONSIBLE FOR HIS
INDIVIDUAL ACTIONS.
IT'S ALSO THE CASE THAT THE
PRESIDENT ENGAGES IN DIVISIVE
SPEECH.
THAT'S THE PROBLEM HERE.
I THINK HE HAS UPPED THE ANTE IN
TERMS OF DIVISIVE SPEECH.
PART OF IT, AND WHAT I HEARD IN
YOUR MONOLOGUE AND FROM LISA IS
BLAME THE PRESS.
THE PRESS IS NOT FAIR TO HIM.
HE HAS GONE BACK TO THE PRESS IS
THE ENEMY OF THE PEOPLE.
I THINK THIS GOES, FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE, BEYOND THAT BECAUSE
HIS RHETORIC IS SO INTENSE THAT
I THINK IT HAS SORT OF CREATED
AN ATMOSPHERE OF MORE KIND OF
DISSIDENCE AND VITRIOL THAN WE
ARE ACCUSTOMED TO.
TO MY MIND, WE HAVE SEEN IN THE
LAST WEEK OR SO, IT MAKES ME
WONDER, IS THIS AMERICA?
HOW DID WE GET TO THIS POINT?
OVER THE WEEKEND, PUT ME ASIDE,
BECAUSE I WORRY THAT YOU'RE
GOING TO SAY THERE IS
JUAN WILLIAMS.
THE PRESS AGAIN.
35,000 PEOPLE, GREG, SAYING THE
PRESIDENT WILL NOT BE WELCOME IN
PITTSBURGH AND THUS HE DENOUNCES
WHITE NATIONALISM.
AND HERE'S WORDS FROM THIS
GROUP, THE JEWISH GROUP, THEY
SAY FOR THE PAST THREE YEARS,
"YOUR WORDS, YOUR POLICIES HAVE
EMBOLDENED A GROWING WHITE
NATIONALIST MOVEMENT.
YOU YOURSELF CALLED THE MURDERER
EVIL.
BUT YESTERDAY'S VIOLENCE IS THE
DIRECT CULMINATION OF YOUR
INFLUENCE."
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW MUCH
ABOUT THAT GROUP BUT I THINK WE
HAVE TAPE FROM CNN WHEN THEY
WERE ASKING THIS SPECIFIC RABBI
FROM THAT SYNAGOGUE ABOUT
WHETHER TRUMP WAS WELCOME THERE.
I THINK WE HAVE THAT.
I AM TALKING SLOW ENOUGH SO YOU
CAN SET IT UP.
DID IT WORK?
>> PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS TALKED
ABOUT COMING TO PITTSBURGH AND
COMING TO YOUR SYNAGOGUE IN THE
AFTERMATH OF THIS.
DO YOU WANT HIM TO COME?
>> THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES IS ALWAYS WELCOME.
I AM A CITIZEN.
HE'S MY PRESIDENT.
HE IS CERTAINLY WELCOME.
>> Greg: KILMEADE, WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Brian: I DON'T KNOW ANY OF
THOSE GROUPS.
SOUNDS LIKE DEMOCRATIC TALKING
POINTS.
SOUNDS LIKE SOMETHING TOM STEYER
SAID ON SUNDAY.
I WAS STUNNED.
IF YOU ASK ME WHEN THIS
HAPPENED, THE BOMBER IS
DISCOVERED AND THEN THE SHOOTING
AT THEIR SYNAGOGUE, I THOUGHT
MAYBE BY SUNDAY, A POND AND
LOOKING TO GET A NETWORK
CONTRACT WOULD GO AHEAD AND SAY
I THINK THE PRESIDENT IS TO
BLAME.
THE SAME DAY, THE SAME DAY,
WITHIN AN HOUR, THEY SAID LOOK
AT WHAT YOU SEE PAIRED WITH THE
PRESIDENT DOES AND IT WORKS TO
HIS DETRIMENT IS HE WATCHED
EVERYBODY TALK ABOUT ALL THIS.
IT HAD HIM SEETHING.
AS IF WE WERE SITTING OUTSIDE
THE GLASS LISTENING TO
"THE FIVE" TALK ABOUT US.
HE'S OUTRAGED.
WHAT DOES THE PRESIDENT DO?
EXACTLY WHAT HE DID HIS ENTIRE
LIFE, AT THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION
AND AS A CANDIDATE AS PRESIDENT.
I'M GOING TO TWEET.
I'M GOING TO SPEAK OUT.
THE WAY YOU TREAT ME, THE
60 MILLION WHO VOTED FOR ME, WE
ARE SEETHING AND READY TO GO.
NOTHING TO DO WITH THAT LUNATIC
IN FLORIDA AND THE NUTCASE IN
PITTSBURGH.
BUT I DO THINK THAT THERE'S A
SENSE OUT THERE THAT TRUMP AND
HIS SUPPORTERS HAVE BEEN
CATEGORIZED AS WHITE NATIONALIST
BECAUSE THEY VOTED FOR HIM AND
THEY ARE TIRED OF IT.
>> Juan: I DON'T THINK IT'S
ABOUT VOTING FOR HIM.
IF YOU LOOK AT THE ACTIONS, NOT
ONLY THE BOMBER AND THE SHOOTER,
BUT GO BACK TO CHARLOTTESVILLE,
ALMOST KINDS OF THINGS, THERE'S
A GROWING WHITE NATIONALIST RAGE
IN THIS COUNTRY.
>> Lisa: YOU DO REALIZE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S DAUGHTER IS
JEWISH.
HIS SON-IN-LAW IS JEWISH.
HIS GRANDCHILDREN ARE JEWISH.
I THINK PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS A
SPECIAL SPOT IN HIS HEART FOR
THE JEWISH COMMUNITY.
YOU SEE THAT IN HIS ACTIONS,
MOVING THE EMBASSY TO JERUSALEM.
BEING THE FIRST SITTING
PRESIDENT OF VISIT THE WESTERN
WALL.
IT'S OFTEN NOT TALKED ABOUT IN
THIS NATIONAL DIALOGUE, THE FACT
THAT IT'S CLOSE TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> Juan: ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT BUGGED ME ABOUT
CHARLOTTESVILLE.
EVERYONE PUT IT IN TERMS OF THE
CONFEDERATE STATUES, BLACK,
WHITE.
THEY HAD GUYS WITH TIKI TORCHES
AND AUTOMATIC WEAPONS STANDING
OUTSIDE IT SYNAGOGUE SO THE
JEWISH PEOPLE HAD TO EXIT OUT
THE BACK DOOR AND THOSE SAME
GUYS AND WHAT A SHAME THAT
MR. TRUMP WOULD ALLOW HIS
BEAUTIFUL DAUGHTER TO MARRY A.
>> Lisa: THEY WERE UNIVERSALLY
CONDEMNED.
>> Greg: THE MEDIA ODDLY
ENOUGH DIDN'T MIND LOUIS
FARRAKHAN'S TWEETS EARLIER THIS
WEEK WHEN HE COMPARED JEWS TO
TERMITES.
YOU AND ANDREW McCARTHY ON
YOUR SHOW.
BACK IN THE 70s, THE
UNITED STATES WAS A MUCH SMALLER
COUNTRY.
MANY, MANY MORE OF THESE KINDS
OF ATTACKS.
>> Dana: "THE NEW YORK TIMES"
YESTERDAY HAD AN AMAZING REPORT.
ON THE WEBSITE, REALLY WELL
DONE.
I WOULD POINT ANYONE TO IT.
TALK ABOUT 1968.
THE 50TH ANNIVERSARY AND WERE
LOOKING AT THIS NOW.
IN 1968, HOW DIVISIVE THINGS
WERE.
I THINK WE HAVE TO KEEP IN MIND
THAT KEEPING A REDLINE BETWEEN
SPEECH AND VIOLENCE IS REALLY
IMPORTANT.
THAT'S HOW AMERICA WAS FOUNDED.
I ALSO FEEL LIKE THE PRESIDENT
COULD FIGURE OUT A WAY TO READ
THE ROOM A LITTLE BETTER AND BY
THAT I MEAN THE COUNTRY.
TAKE, MINUTES.
TAP THE BRAKES A LITTLE BIT.
FOR BETTER OR WORSE, PEOPLE TEND
TO LOOK UP TO LEADERS MAY WANT
TO FEEL BETTER ABOUT THE MOMENT.
THE MOMENT BECOMES ABOUT HIM AND
THE MEDIA TREATMENT OF HIM, THEN
WE ARE RIGHT BACK DOWN INTO IT.
SOMEONE IS GOING TO HAVE TO STEP
FORWARD AND DO SOMETHING.
ONE LAST THING AND THEN WE HAVE
TO GO.
THE ISSUE OF RADICALIZATION OF
PEOPLE.
WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT THIS A LOT
DURING THE WAR ON TERROR.
HOW DOES THAT HAPPEN?
YOU HAVE HOPELESS PEOPLE,
PURPOSELESS PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO
ARE IGNORANT AND THEY FIND
PURPOSE IN SOMETHING THAT THEY
FIND SOMEWHERE.
NOW IT'S ONLINE.
RADICAL ISLAMISTS.
HOW DO THEY FIND IT?
THERE'S ALWAYS SOMETHING.
I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK IT IS
SPEECH BUT THERE IS A
CULMINATION OF A DEBT IF YOU
LOOK AT THIS GUY'S BACKGROUND,
BOWERS' BACKGROUND, HE CERTAINLY
HAD IT.
HE TURNED EVIL AND VILE, TURNED
INTO VIOLENCE.
THE PRESIDENT SAYS --
WHAT IS IT IN YOUR POWER TO DO?
ON COMFORTABLE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT PRIVACY.
WE CAN PROSECUTE VERY WELL.
WHAT WE DON'T BE ABLE TO DO AS
WELL AS PREVENT.
>> Greg: YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT
PREVENTED INSTITUTIONALIZATION
WAS THERE FOR UNSTABLE
INDIVIDUALS.
WE DON'T HAVE THAT ANYMORE.
THERE ARE A LOT OF UNSAVORY,
UNSTABLE PEOPLE.
WE DON'T KNOW WHERE TO PUT THEM.
THIS OTHER GUY, THE BOMBER, HE
WAS HIDING IN PLAIN SIGHT.
>> Dana: 5 MINUTES BEFORE HE
LEFT, HE BOASTED "I CAN'T TAKE
THIS ANYMORE" BECAUSE IT
COULDN'T TAKE ANYMORE REFUGEES
COMING IN, SUPPORTED BY THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY.
5 MINUTES BEFORE.
5 MINUTES FROM POSTING TO
SHOOTING.
>> Brian: AS COMPOSED AS
BARACK OBAMA IS, HIS
CHARISMATIC, SPEECH.
KATHY GIFFORDS, SANDY HOOK.
HE MIGHT FLAP THE HANDLE TOO.
>> Juan: YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO
TALKED ABOUT HOPE AND CHANGE IN
SOMEONE WHO PRESSES THE FEAR